[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: The brain is a magical organ.
For us to hear sound, it does
things complex and incredible,
but not unknowable.
The brain takes sound waves
which journey through the air
and through our skulls and transforms
them into sound in our minds.
This sonic odyssey is beautiful,
filled with weird landscapes,
unexpected encounters,
catastrophe, and joyful
destinations, all like a
strange aural fairy tale.
Hearing evolved because it
helped animals to survive.
Hearing allowed predators
to find prey and eat them,
and hearing allowed prey to
spy on predators and to escape.
The floppy piece of skin
attached to the sides of our head
is our outer ear, or pinna.
It collects sounds from a
wide area of our evironment,
like a reflector disk
of a satellite dish.
In humans, the pinna is in a fixed
position, but in many animals,
the pinna are highly flexible and can
be oriented toward a source of sound.
Curiously, our auditory
system has evolved
beyond it's strict utility of survival.
For example, music,
through its perception
of sound by our auditory system,
evokes sensations and emotions.
Sound is produced when
something vibrates,
causing variations in air pressure.
Particles of air collide with other
particles, and the wave of movement
bouncing from particle to particle
passes outward through the air.
This is called a sound wave.
And now our brave sound waves
are approaching the outer ear
and are truly starting their journey.
Once they have entered
the ear through the pinna,
they pass down the air-filled auditory
canal before hitting the eardrum.
As the sound waves strike the
eardrum, the vibrations in the air
are transferred through that membrane
into a series of little bones
called the ossicles.
There are three bones in this group,
the malleus, incus, and stapes,
also known as the hammer,
anvil, and stirrup.
They function to transmit sounds
from the air-filled outer ear
into the fluid-filled inner
ear by allowing the sound
to enter them through the
eardrum, vibrate through them,
and then exit into the inner ear via a
second membrane called the oval window.
The inner ear contains the
sensory organs for both hearing
as well as for our sense of balance.
The cochlea, an important
organ for the auditory process,
is snail-shaped and if rolled up,
is only about the size of a pea.
Inside the cochlea is
the organ of Corti,
which sits on the basilar membrane
and below the tectorial membrane.
And inside the organ of Corti are
thousands of auditory hair cells.
These hair cells are, in fact,
receptor neurons called stereocilia.
These hair cells convert the
motion energy of sound waves
into electrical signals that are
communicated to the auditory nerve.
From there, the signal goes into
structures deeper in the brain
until at last, it reaches the
auditory cortex, where we consciously
experience sound.
To back up, when our sound waves
enter the fluid-filled inner ear,
they are thrust into a
storm, a storm of vibrations
that they are, in fact, creating.
The basilar membrane below them is
violently shaking and tossing them.
The tectorial membrane above
them is moving back and forth
and pushing and threatening.
And in the midst of this maelstrom,
as they are broken apart,
they spiral through the inner
ear and the sound waves finally
begin to weaken.
The inner ear absorbs all
their kinetic strength,
and the sound waves begin to
realize that this will be their end.
Now, finally, in the chaos of
the inner ear, they disappear.
The sound waves have ceased to be, but
though the vibrations are now no more,
they are not completely gone.
They have metamorphosed into
something new, into neural activity.
And they come to life again
in the cortex of the brain.
In the consciousness of our
minds, their journey is over.
The brain has taken what was
outside and made it inside.
[MUSIC PLAYING]